Hello world.
It's the Raj and let's learn about a
popular new deep learning framework called
Pi Torch. The name is inspired by the
popular torch deep learning framework,
which was written in the Lua
programming language. Learning.
Lula is a big barrier to entry if you're
just starting to learn deep learning
and it doesn't offer the
modularity necessary to
interface with other libraries
like a more accessible language would.
So a couple of AI researchers who were
inspired by torches programming style
decided to implement it in
python calling it high torch.
They also added a few other really cool
features to the mix and we'll talk about
the two main ones. The first key feature
of Pi Torch is imperative programming.
An imperative program performs
computation as you typed it.
Most Python code is imperative
and this num py example,
we write four lines of code to ultimately
compute the value for d when the
program executes c Equals d times a.
It runs the actual computation than
in there just like you told it to.
In contrast and it's symbolic program,
there is a clear separation
between defining the
computation graph and compiling
it.
If we were to rewrite the
same code symbolically than
when c Equals d times a is
executed, no computation
occurs at that line. Instead,
these operations generate a computation
or symbolic graph and then we can
convert the graft into a function that
can be called via the compile step.
So computation happens as
the last step in the code.
Both styles have there tradeoffs.
Symbolic programs are more efficient
since you can safely reuse the memory of
your values. For inplace
computation, tensorflow is
made to use symbolic program.
Imperative programs are more flexible
since python is most suited for them.
So you can use native python features
like printing out values in the middle of
computation and injecting loops
into the computation flow itself.
The second key feature of Pi Torch is
dynamic computation graphing as opposed to
static computation graphing. In other
words, Pi Torch is defined by run.
So at runtime the system
generates the graph structure.
Tensorflow is defined and run where
we defined conditions and iterations.
In the graph structure, it's like writing
the whole program before running it.
So the degree of freedom is limited.
So in tensorflow we defined
the computation graph once,
then we can execute that
same graph many times.
The great thing about this is that we
can optimize the graph at the start.
Let's say in our model we want to use
some kind of strategy for distributing the
graph across multiple machines.
This kind of computationally expensive
optimization can be reduced by reusing
the same graph.
Static graphs worked well for neural
networks that are fixed size like
feedforward networks or
convolutional networks,
but for a lot of use cases it would
be useful if the graph structure could
change depending on the input data,
like when using recurrent neural networks.
In this snippet,
we're using tensorflow to unroll a
recurrent network unit overboard vectors.
To do this, we'll need to use a special
tensorflow function called wild.
We have to use special nodes to represent
primitives like loops and conditionals
because any control flow statements will
run only once when the graph is built.
But a cleaner way to do this is to
use dynamic graphs instead where the
computation graph is built and
rebuilt as necessary. At runtime,
the code is more straightforward.
Since we can use standard four
and if statements, anytime.
The amount of work that
needs to be done is variable.
Dynamic graphs are useful using dynamic
graphs makes debugging really easy since
a specific line in our written code is
what fails as opposed to something deep
under section.run.
Let's build a simple two layer neural
network in Pi torch to get a feel for the
syntax. We start by importing
our framework as well as
the autograph package,
which we'll let our network
automatically implement backpropagation.
Then we'll define our batch size,
input dimension,
hidden dimension and output dimension.
We'll then use those values to help
define tensors to hold inputs and outputs.
Wrapping them in variables we'll set
requires gradients to false since we don't
need to compute gradients with respect to
these variables during backpropagation.
The next set of variables
we'll define our our weights.
We'll initialize them
as variables as well,
storing random tensors with the float
data type and since we do want to compute
gradients with respect to these variables,
we'll set the flag to true.
We'll define a learning rates and we
can begin our training loop for 500
iterations.
During the forward pass,
we can compute the predicted label
using operations on our variables.
Mm stands for Matrix
multiply and clamp clamps.
All the elements in the input range
into a range between men and Max.
Once we've matrix multiplied for both
sets of weights to compute our prediction,
we can calculate the difference
between them and square it,
the sum of all the squared errors,
a popular loss function.
Before we perform backpropagation,
we need to manually zero the
gradients for both sets of weights.
Since the gray and buffers have to be
manually reset before fresh grades are
calculated,
then we can run back propagation by simply
calling the backward function on our
loss, it will compute the grain of our
loss with respect to all variables we set
requires gradient the true for,
and then we can update our weights
using gradient descent and our outputs.
We'll look great. Pretty Dope. To sum up,
high torch offers to really useful
features, dynamic computation graphs,
and imperative programming.
Dynamic computation.
Graphs are built and rebuilt as necessary
at runtime and imperative programs
perform computation as you run them.
There is no distinction between defining
the computation graph and compiling.
Right now,
tensorflow has the best documentation on
the web for a machine learning library,
so it's still the best way for beginners
to start learning and it's best suited
for production use since it was built
with distributed computing in mind.
But for researchers, it seems like
Pi Torch has a clear advantage here.
A lot of cool new ideas will benefit
and rely on the use of dynamic grass.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos. And for now, I've got a torch,
my hair,
so thanks for watching.